le saut de porte-voix est la séquence dont Tom et
moi parlons depuis un certain nombre d'
années. Tom sera le premier acteur à faire
un saut de
halo devant la caméra.  dans
le pays étranger sans être
détecté c'est l'idée de Halo
il y a beaucoup de risques à aller à
25 000 pieds le public peut dire quand
quelque chose a été trompé il semble
important de tout faire pour de vrai
il y a des dangers d'hypoxie et les virages que
vous commencez à perdre  votre esprit mais vous ne vous en rendez pas
compte nous avons dû développer un
casque spécial qui est à la fois un accessoire et un
dispositif de sauvetage la première phase de
la séquence bonjour consistait à construire une éolienne
suffisamment grande pour que
nous puissions répéter  nous construisons donc l'une
des plus grandes souffleries au monde, personne ne
pensait qu'il faudrait plus d'une centaine de
sauts pour obtenir la scène dont nous avions besoin aux
EAU s'ils n'étaient pas intervenus, nous
n'aurions pas pu accomplir le
se  séquence, nous avons fait cinq sauts par
jour sur le Twin Otter l'après-midi,
nous ferons trois sauts en c-17 et c'est
difficile,
nous tournons une séquence de nuit, la
lumière doit être parfaite,
nous allons obtenir un coup par  jour, vous
devez le filmer aussi près que possible du coucher du soleil
afin que nous ayons exactement trois minutes chaque
jour pour prendre la photo, vous ne pouvez pas simplement monter
dans l'avion et partir, vous devez passer 20
minutes au sol à respirer de l'
oxygène pur pour que  vous n'attrapez pas le
mal de décompression l'avion doit
monter à 25 000 pieds tout l'éclairage
passe du blanc au rouge vous parlez
de Tom sautant d'un avion
voyage à 165 milles à l'heure
tombant à 200 milles à l'heure et Kista
positionnez-vous de manière à atterrir
exactement à trois pieds de la caméra
avec 20 000 pieds sous lui le risque d'
une collision en vol qui nous
préoccupait vraiment il y a toujours un compte à
rebours pour filmer un film mais ce n'est
généralement pas la terre qui vole vers vous
merci beau téléphone  J'ai
hâte qu'un public voie ça, je
n'arrive toujours pas à croire que nous l'avons
compris  était heureuse de montrer son devoir Missy
wookie seulement voxel opposé utiliser le GPS jusqu'à un
pompier déposition de Lynn sativa il a rencontré
Nora surveiller le salami rebondissant donc Dorothea
musici conception scalpel
piranha
SEPA a besoin d'une gorgée ne demande qu'un choc pour
Annette plus au Nevada kupo observation
s'installer en Jamaïque de  Scott wha
seaweedy ils arrivent à Davi dire du
soldat moelleux si vite résolu
Tribble Benji oh mon Dieu maîtresse du tout
elle t'a agressé avec tout ce que
Tony et lui dit de me faire circuler dit
pathologie Takeshi Donnelly a dit non
Sandra Python
magnifiquement concession
[Musique  ]
sauf Allah écrit tsuki FFXIII chameau
c'est termine Condesa dog city Je veux dire une
fête
[Musique]
échange les retombées de l'acéton au cinéma
toi